the US government is calling the corona
virus outbreak a public health emergency
on Friday a seventh case of the virus
was confirmed in the United States at
least 191 other people are being
monitored for the disease in order to
limit the spread anyone traveling to the
u.s. from China's Hubei province where
the disease originated will face a
mandatory 14 day quarantine starting
Sunday that's tomorrow nearly 200 US
citizens evacuated from China are being
held at a military base in Southern
California but health officials say the
risk of infection is low it's the bread
and butter I've talked to you before
about the bread and butter of public
health is identify people who might be
symptomatic or might have the disease
diagnosed isolate treat contact trace
this is the first time in more than 50
years that the federal government has
ordered a quarantine Chinese health
officials said today another 46 people
have died from the corona virus upping
the total now to 259 and the official
number of infections is nearly 12,000
making this larger than the SARS
outbreak in 2002 in 2003 millions of
people in central China where the
outbreak began are for the most part
confined to their homes the largest
quarantine in human history
Raymie innocencio is at Beijing's
capital airport with the latest
Ramy good morning good morning and fears
of more infections are playing out in
the United States and around the world
the Trump administration says it will
now bar foreign nationals entering the
United States if they've been here to
China in the 14 days before they arrived
now direct flights from Beijing Shanghai
and other Chinese cities are being
frozen or cut even more that's what
American Delta and United announced on
Friday more European and Asian carriers
are doing similar now that's after the
World Health Organization declared
coronavirus a global health emergency
and after the State Department raised
its travel advisory for China to its
highest a level four which means do not
travel to China for comparison that's
the same as North Korea Iran
and Iraq China's foreign ministry on
Twitter implied the USS ban on anyone
having just visited from China was
overreacting
meanwhile in central China and
coronavirus ground zero more than 50
million people are still on some kind of
partial or total lockdown one of the two
hospitals to treat patients is almost
finished but infection numbers keep
rising in a new study the british
medical journal the lancet estimates
that more than 75 thousand people were
infected last week now if that is true
that would confirm fears that many
people already have that beijing is
massively under reporting these numbers
for CBS this morning saturday rainy
Inocencio beijing it's just frightening
when you hear that idea of the largest
quarantine in human history but times
have certainly changed right we have
part of it we access an ability to do
that right but so many people I think
are afraid that folks will panic there's
certainly an impact on tourism I know
people who were planning to go and
aren't now you hope there's enough
communication between China and the US
and everyone else so everyone tries to
get on the same page so it can be
contained but yes it is worrisome right
now
[Music]